Are you still hungry takes a lot of energy to summon my chi
What you made quite a great team now?
I'm looking for superfriends me neither. You keep on telling yourself
- the hell are you God is going to help you say necessary
The war for New York is here
They haven't noticed everything
Not yet, so get your shit together. We have time to grab a drink
Let's go do something Crazy I
Only went back. There's no karate
Danny but it oh I can see you form upon here. I
Promise you it's temporary if I can help it
So call immediate it's kind of cool
Everybody new defenders trailer this might actually wind up being the last one
But what's going to happen is I'll explain my video schedule for the episodes when it drops next week
So if you didn't know it's dropping on Friday, but you should probably start watching it Thursday night at midnight
So if you can swing it I recommend you do that, but I love the way they cut this trailer
It's meant to be a little more humorous like they had this really awesome chemistry on-screen together
It'll talk a little bit more about how they come together when I post my first review video later this week
It'll be non spoilery
But they do dedicate a lot of time to try and blending the tone of all the characters so that even though the show
Carries a lot of the stuff that's come before with it like you begin with moments with each of the characters
Separately so you sort of refresh your memory about what's going on in their own individual universes
And then a couple big wtF moments happen they start clashing and they come together
So when they're in this restaurant sizing each other up
It's actually the first time that they all come together watching Danny ran stuff his face, but then stick comes along and explains
What's actually going on like look this is the war for New York then the hand gets the drop on them you see Alexandre
Sort of tell them to back off like now is your last chance this isn't going to end well for you
You even see Elektra come in at this point
- she's still wearing that big Trench coat of hers
But then they start jumping around in time like you have this training moment. Where dick is trying to explain everything to them
They're interrogating this person at the end of the trailer luke 8 is like yeah, I guess you know daredevils pretty cool
He had that Billy clubs pretty neat and you get a couple really good shots of how funny and awesome it is to watch them
take people down like they have a couple different shots as they cut together of this big hallway fight so like everybody has their
Daredevil Hallway fight in like the fourth or fifth episode of each of the series
So of course think of the epic hallway fight that they have to have in defenders now that they're all together
So if you slow the trailer down they actually cut it a little bit weirdly like they jump around in time during this
Individual scene so you have luke cage
crashing through the side of the hallway like he literally rammed some dude through the wall here as
Matt is walking down punching someone like he normally would
Jessica Jones throwing people around iron fists going crazy and in most of these shots you have Elektra
Just casually walking up behind them, so I'm guessing because the daredevil isn't turning around freaking out
He doesn't know what her status is at this point, and she's still working for Alexandra
This shot here looks like it's from later in that scene where elektra is either getting ready to try and kill matt or iron fist
And he just obliterated her sword with his chi the really cool thing about this, too
Is that iron fist they sort of upgrade his power levels through this series?
But there's still going to be a lot of ground to cover when they get to iron fist season two but remember how Madame gao
also kind of
Understands how to harness her chi not to the level that iron fist can but you see them underground here like in this underground pit
area that we saw during daredevil season two going up against the hand and luke cage says light him up and he just
Unleashes the Iron fist and just blows them all back
She's got her fists extended here
So I'll be interested to see what kind of badass move she has
Because they've been hyping madame gao up for a long time, and if she's sort of the underdog to Alexandra
It makes you wonder what's going on with her like what kind of crazy power does she have as of right now
It sounds like she's an original character not from the comics, but that could always change they could always reveal her as someone else
But I'm not
expecting her to wind up being the demon that they worshipped because that's
supposed to be who black sky is like the people that harness the energy of the demon become conduits for him to come back into
this plane of existence
The effects actually look really good. It looks like they really did spend the extra money on this
I love the way that Luke cages arm gives off
Sparks when Elektra tries to slash him you even get a little bit of a heroes for hire
Moment where iron fist is hiding behind him here using them as a human shield
But when episodes drop you guys will see like they're still working up to heroes for hire stuff
They don't genuinely get any like really big moments like that because they're just coming together for the first time
But you do feel that chemistry so you will wonder after this why don't they just do a heroes for hire?
series
And I have a couple theories for why that is but mostly I think it's just
Contractual on Netflix's end and for those of you asking a lot of people have been messaging me about this Disney Marvel
Netflix deal that's supposedly going away soon
The big thing that happened recently is the Disney announced that it was going to develop its own streaming service
And it was going to put all of its content there
So it was taking it off of Netflix even if that does wind up happening that doesn't include
Marvel and Netflix is deal for these TV shows netflix owns the rights to those like they're literally paying for these to happen
It's not like they're licensing content from Marvel
it's just like star wars movies the marvel movies the stuff that Netflix bias to redistribute punisher would still be okay to
And I know we haven't seen any new trailers for that yet
But that's really just because they're mostly pushing defenders right now like they'll be hitting it pretty hard next week with this stuff
But I would expect that within the next couple weeks after people have a chance to watch defenders
Then they'll start teasing out more punisher stuff
I know you all want to know if punishers part of defenders you have to remember that when they were filming this TV series
They were also filming the punisher TV series too. So it was just a question of scheduling
So just don't expect punisher to show up in high five everybody every single episode, but he's still part of this universe
So they'll probably a couple really interesting surprises later in the series
part of the fun of this series is seeing all the weird pairings my
Favorite new pairing of characters that you haven't seen together before is Jessica Jones and daredevil
You've seen some of their earliest scenes in the trailer where he just busts in and tries to help her get out of prison
You have interrupted a citywide investigation
You stole evidence from my crime scene?
And you got my one lead killed I?
Was trying to help him, but you didn't
Just stop talking how the hell are you my name is Matthew murdock. I'm her attorney
So once you do get a chance to see the first couple of episodes let me know in the comments
Who's your favorite new pairing because you have all these characters sometimes?
There's just a couple of them on-screen together and everybody wants to see some heroes for hire at some point
They're meeting on screen is really awesome
For a whole different reason if you were kind of bummed out by iron fist
And not really happy about the character you will love the first time that they meet on screen. It's hilarious
They have been doing a lot of interviews
So if you guys want me to post some of their interview videos they said some interesting stuff
So leave all your bonus video requests in the comments below be sure to subscribe to get everything and there will be a new Marvel
Giveaway when I start posting episode videos so my first non-spoilery review will post next week
Maybe by like Wednesday, so while you wait for all that you can click here for more defenders
And you can click here for my infinity war trailer video. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight